foreign
[Music]
the Warring States period a time
spanning two and a half centuries in
which China was divided into seven
states engaged in constant War over land
and Supremacy across the realm
period defined by the emergence of some
of the most legendary generals and
warriors to be recorded within the
annals of History who led China onto its
historic path to power
six great generals of chin
the three great heavens of Zhao
the six fire dragons of whey
these genius strategic minds and Fierce
warmongers clashed and brought immense
success to their allies and utter
Annihilation to their foes
little did they know however of a young
pair of abandoned slaves sparring with
wooden swords and a small insignificant
Village and Southern chin who would
single-handedly come to change the
future of all of China and aspire to
become the greatest generals under the
heavens
this is the story of kingdom
laughs
I knew little to nothing before coming
into Kingdom but for a manga to run ever
since 2006 and a crew 68 volumes and
Counting speaks volumes to yasuhi
Sahara's work the mangaka and a couple
weeks ago I began Kingdom knowing that I
was about to undertake a lengthy Journey
Through the 750 plus chapters of this
ongoing story what did take me by
surprise though was that already within
200 chapters this manga skyrocketed to
become easily one of my favorite manga
that I've ever had the pleasure of
reading
the series has sold nearly 100 million
copies and has even earned a Guinness
world record in 2012 as the manga
written by the most people
how is that possible one might Ascot
that's what I asked before I was blessed
enough to witness the social Kingdom a
campaign that gave the task of redrawing
an entire volume of Kingdom to fans and
other artists in one of the coolest
collections of artwork I've ever seen I
mean how often do you get to see
takihiko inoe's beautiful artwork side
by side with the indiscernible scribbles
of an unnamed fan single Pages alone
might give you a drawing by each hero
Oda the author of One Piece followed by
a spread containing superbly detailed
and traditional Asian art and then
the the darkest most depraved looking
frame to ever be drawn on a manga page
it's incredibly fun and creative and so
many people coming together to recreate
one of this story's best volumes is a
testament to its greatness truly
[Music]
now Kingdom follows a young Brash
headstrong and frankly quite stupid boy
named Shin who has one dream to become a
general unrivaled under the heavens
and as you might expect the story
follows him as he grows older and
pursues just that in a fashion that for
me felt comfortably nostalgic reminding
me of shonen's most classic characters
those who shaped my childhood
there is something comforting about the
era of the early 2000s that defined its
Shonen stories by these strong stupid
but bold protagonists that we all love
so deeply and fully
a part of me felt that despite how much
we've seen this type of main character
before as anime and manga readers being
able to read Kingdom now as I'm older
has given me more appreciation for that
archetype and what shin and the rest of
these characters truly represent
unadulterated uninhibited
Shin is the type of character who will
never fall until he achieves his dream
and what makes that character so amazing
within their respective stories isn't
just that they won't fall it's seeing
that belief being imbued in his friends
allies comrades
their confidence that Shin is a Pillar
of Strength for them all
it's not that he can't fall but that he
never will it's a it's a fact in all of
their heads
but the one thing that really
differentiates Kingdom from those other
stories for me is how this very
cartoonish archetypal fictional
protagonist is born into such an utterly
real world
foreign
events found in the shiji a historic
record written and compiled in the Han
Dynasty that kept records of a total of
3 000 years of Chinese history this
means that yes if you know all the
details of the Warring States period in
China have read the shiji you might know
how the story ends but even if that's
the case in no way does that knowledge
detract one bit from just how enjoyable
this manga is
because despite being based on real
history the shiji is little more than a
labeled timeline the characters their
stories their paths they are all
meticulously crafted by yasuhi Sahara to
make it so that these destination points
along the Chinese historical timeline
feel just as Monumental as they really
were
I mean what is history besides a couple
dates without the context to add the
weight to it
in my opinion there are few things more
exciting and entertainment than in
historical fiction or stories based on
real events when the story actually
refers to the real events and there is
no shortage of these moments in Kingdom
when you are greeted at the end of a
surreal twisted and mind-boggling story
arc with a quote from the shiji stating
that this is 100 true
this feeling of real stakes and history
grounds the story and makes the story
feel so crazy because this is just
history and normal people and it
shouldn't be this crazy and unbelievable
but it simply was
well yes the characters personalities
for the most part their strength level
skills and the like they've been
fabricated by the mangaka showing a good
degree of creative freedom and fudging
the line between history and fiction but
despite all of that
Kingdom slaps you in the face almost
every chapter with the hard-hitting
truth this is history believe your eyes
and this real world clashes with Shin's
character
because despite how the Warring States
period in China sounds this was not just
a world dominated by strength
Shin is strong and
kind of dumb but it isn't as simple as
just picking a fight and beating your
enemy all the time
story of Kingdom shows us in times of
War just how much more exists beyond the
battlefield
you have to think of this in the sense
of real life
what decides the fate of war is it the
strength of its Warriors is it the
quality of their weapons
no
strategists that manipulate the battle
to become what they desire it's a
politicians who decide when and where to
act and when to wage war
this is how real war is
Kingdom never fails to show not only how
strong Shin is but how weak he is as
well
War isn't just battle it's atrocities
and violence of extreme scales pillaging
torture backstabbing
Shin is a pure soul in our world that
accepts and often encourages that kind
of behavior to the so-called Victors of
War
Shin is good in a terrible place which
once again makes his actions and rise to
power throughout the story feel all the
more well-deserved and prideful for us
as readers
but at the same time the story always
shows us that Shin's way of thinking can
also be thought of as very naive
Shin wants to become a great general of
war and yet he refuses to accept certain
ways that war has always worked though
his character feels very Shonen very
simple at first glance kingdom is
incredibly thought provoking to read
because you're transporting this naive
pure and strong type of character into a
story that is almost entirely the
opposite of that
where strategists betray each other and
fill the battlefield with innumerable
twists and turns of tactics and the
greatest generals allowed their soldiers
to pillage and commit atrocities as much
as they want if it means they will be
the victors and the politics of War
force you to hold yourself back from
doing something you know should or must
be done yet cannot because a person of
power tells you not to
this is reality
kingdom is a story about war it's it's
dark you see things you don't want to
see and what makes it all the worse is
knowing that it isn't just some
fictional depraved characters doing this
acts you can't separate yourself from it
because it's real history
the Battle of chongping where chin
soldiers are said to have killed four
hundred thousand surrendered Soldiers by
burying them alive
these aren't the kinds of moments that
you can easily swallow
and as I said Kingdom makes it very
clear that war is not something to be
glorified even though yes it is a story
all about war
because there is a ray of Hope in
everything
and that hope is shin
it is the people in the world who show
us that there is something worth
fighting for and believing in and his
victories in battle as he strives to
achieve his dream despite the world
fighting against him make Kingdom one of
the greatest manga I've ever read
in this sense Kingdom makes the idea of
a general very real with being the
strongest or Hokage or wizard King it
simply means power and respect when you
think about it it's challenging to
conceptualize all these different
powerful and achieving positions but
being a general isn't just that will we
witness alongside Shin's growth as a
character is a growth in his dream of
being a general unrivaled under the
Heavens to be a general is to be willing
to send your men to their deaths for the
greater good to not abandon their lives
and forget them to a cause but instead
take their deaths with you as another
burden on your shoulders that pushes you
to make sure you succeed that the troops
you send to follow them don't fall to
the same fate
be a general is to view the battlefield
in a way that no one else sees and guide
your troops to a fate they will likely
not even understand but you know it will
lead to certain victory
to be a general is to be at both the
Forefront and the backbone of each and
every Soldier under your command that is
what Shin learns is far more important
than just the label of General
to be called a general is far different
from what it means to really be one
[Music]
I truly believe there are few manga of
as epic of a scale as Kingdom and I
cannot recommend it enough
thanks for watching guys I know it's
been a while
as always this has been the anime
culture corner I hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like And subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyzes